behind the camera if you stand like this
you don't you don't
thus in Vietnam for example I would just
step in in true cross fire into sniper
fire and and shoot their film and many
of them got killed because you feel a
perfect safety behind the camera it's a
very very strange effect once you hold a
camera and and and you shoot like like
this gentleman here he I'm sure he even
if I approached him with a loaded gun he
would not feel any fear anymore and
count on it now I'm sure he's a he's a
good professional he has a face of a of
a very good professional I like his face
and it's always a camera sometimes i
intruding and sometimes I are just
jumping at you but there are also
sympathetic cameras and and I like to
look at his face it's I feel I feel
sympathy and that's okay I feel good in
his presence and that's a magic of
Cinematographers there there are there
are not many cinematographers like him
maybe I hold the camera and reverse it
at you other than this is the main here
here is it in focus yeah I think so
always in focus yeah this is a man here
I pointed him yeah good yes a big hand
for this man here this man 2 yes
sympathetic microphone yes